what you're saying is extremely
misogynistic yes
thank you women in the workplace
yeah translation I have been banned from
my own conference room so that Jan can
talk in secret to all the girls oh sorry
women of the workplace about what I
don't know close me
Meredith I would like you to pretend
that you are from Abu Dhabi
hello I am ashamed at your naked face
I must cover it with my jacket
you are now sexy in your culture
some guy exposed himself to Phyllis in
the parking lot
really is she okay yeah Bob Vance took
her for a walk to calm down
okay
feel as you say
hmm
what is so funny
um I mean did you even see Pam
or uh Karen from behind I'm guessing not
I'm sorry
foreign
it's disgusting and demeaning oh okay
masters of Comedy a guy dropped his
pants have you ever been to the circus
okay
he's back
[Applause]
okay
oh man you should order milk
get it
why do I like Hooters
well I will give you two reasons the
boobs and the hot wings
oh here we go here we go bogey at three
o'clock hi hey I'm Dana and welcome to
Hooters we're not where are they we're
not worthy
hello Dana I am Michael and this is Jim
and we are brothers nope
we're not Brothers I'm his boss actually
and I treat him well I'm taking him out
to lunch because I can afford it and he
can have whatever he wants I just have
the ham and cheese sandwich thanks and
for you tell me Dana how was your
chicken breast oh it's great it's served
with our world famous wing sauce mmm
sounds yummy I will have a chicken
breast hold the chicken
is that what you really want
no I'm gonna have the gourmet hot dog
great
I wanted to say that the guys downstairs
are thinking about forming a union and
they have some good point a union I'm
not part of my job is knowing how to
talk to women let's be rational here
what are the pros what are the colors
the cons are that everyone will lose
their job Michael everyone office
warehouse
what do you think
are
don't talk to me that way please this is
a masculine environment we need to find
a place where you feel comfortable you
know we're gonna go
steam Town Mall
all right girls break it up you're being
infiltrated
[__] in the hen house Cox in the hen
house don't say Cox no
uh what is your name Affair Lass
Katie ah Katie wow look at you you are
uh you're like the new and improved pam
pam 6.0
oh look oh hey no cat fights you too I'm
against violence in the workplace oh my
and nobody cares who you think it
doesn't matter
you know what
I love Phyllis
you know what else
I think she is gorgeous I think she is
an incredibly incredibly attractive
person
you know what the only thing I am
worried about is getting a boner
good work today everybody
today's fast pace
hard to know when a comment or an action
crosses the line
let's take a look at a couple of
scenarios and ask ourselves where is the
line
Emery
tell Mike
hey settle a bet
are you a natural redhead
oh hey stop the video we go stop it
right there stop it right there
that's that girl from that thing
I'll bang this girl right here yes this
is the one you remember yeah
right here you are a naughty
okay okay
she is a hypocrite that is such a scam
okay yes
yes I did okay well we can talk about
that later then okay you are never gonna
believe this the girl in the video we're
watching the corporate gave us Daryl
banger
and he's about 90 sure
a penis
when seen in the right context
is the most wonderful sight for a woman
but in the wrong context it is like a
monster movie Alien I wonder it's shot
it shut up
okay so what I want to engage Us in
today is a hardcore discussion about
women's problems and issues and
situations magazines and TV shows and
movies portray women as skinny tall
goddesses well look around
are women like that
no
no they are not
even the hot ones aren't really that
skinny
so what does that say that says that you
women are up against it and it is
Criminal Society doesn't care society
sucks I don't even consider myself a
part of society
FYI because I am so angry over all of
this if it were up to me
you ladies would be the fashion models
yes Indie then the fashion models could
come here and work with me what you're
saying is extremely misogynistic yes
thank you
that was not necessary but I appreciated
it and proves my point women can do
anything I'm saying that you're being
sexist no I'm being misogynistic that is
insane I'm not being sexist
yes when I got my haircut chart you
asked me if I was a lesbian
because wow that was one possible
explanation
periods to know whether you're serious
or not you know something Dwight we are
not the terrorists why don't you just
take these women put them in a burlap
sack and hit him with a stick because
that's what you're doing I celebrate
these women they deserve the right to
dress as they please if Pam wants to
show more cleavage she should be able to
I encourage that
look it's really simple we just want you
guys to treat us with respect see that's
what we're talking about did you hear
that Dwight yes
did you hear that Michael no Dwight
respect
r-e-s-p-v-t find out what it means to me
all right everybody oh my God Pam
those make you look so ugly
um Pam in order to get hotter you take
glasses off you're moving in the wrong
direction
I can't even hear you it's just noise
coming out of an ugly scientist
um see we have the entire floor so this
is my kingdom as far as the eye can see
ah this is our receptionist Pam
Pam Beasley uh Pam has been with us
um for forever right Pam well I don't
know if you think she's cute now you
should have seen her a couple of years
ago all right all right what
oh
hey man who says he totally understands
women is a fool
because they are ununderstandable
there's a wishing fountain at the mall
and I threw a coin in for every woman in
the world and made a wish
I wished for Jan to get over me
I wished for Phyllis a plasma TV I
wished for Pam to gain courage
I wished for Angela a heart
and for Kelly a brain
Michael how can you appreciate women so
much but also dump one of them
you mean
how can I be so illogical and flighty
and unpredictable and
emotional
well maybe I learned something from
women after all
yes I was the first one out and yes I've
heard women and children first but we do
not employ children we are not a
sweatshop thankfully and women are equal
in the workplace by law
so I let them out first I have a lawsuit
on my hands
all right